writing is a way of contributing to the
political climate and saying something
meaningful
because not all of us are going to run
for office i'm never going to run for
office my past is filthy
writing is such a great career but you
definitely don't need to be a writer to
enjoy this class
for one of incredibly charming
writing has always influenced public
opinion it's
one of the most effective means of
reaching a great number of people
and to get other people on board with
progressive ideas like women or people
and black lives matter and everyone
should have health care
i know that these are very radical ideas
but writing for social change is really
just writing to make a difference in
this world
in this master class you're going to
learn how to write
better think deeper and contribute your
voice to the world in valuable ways
and we're going to talk about the
business of publishing and how to really
get a start one of the things that we
should always try to do as writers
is to figure out what can you bring to
this discussion
that no one else can i mean that feels
more fun to me
isn't it more fun
perfection is not the goal when you're
writing excellence is
hunger is a memoir that i wrote about my
body
and it starts with a sexual assault i
experienced when i was 12
and i turned to food as a source of
comfort and as a source of protection
thinking that if i made myself bigger i
would become safer
my body is a cage my body is a cage of
my own making
i am still trying to figure my way out
of it i have been trying to figure my
way out of it
for more than 20 years it was a very
difficult book to write
because i was afraid you don't need to
be brave when you're writing you need to
acknowledge that you're terrified and do
it anyway
but don't think that trauma is the only
thing you have to offer you can write
about
anything writing for a lot of people
ends up being salvation
and when writing finds you when writing
saves you
it opens up a whole new world of
possibility and i hope that certainly is
the case for you
i'm roxanne gay and this is my master
[Music]
class
[Music]
you